>> Sauer: Hi. I'm Fred Sauer. I'm a developer
advocate with Google. And I have today with
me three guys with a great idea, great application
that they built on top of App Engine. We'd
like to talk about that today. So maybe you
guys can start with how you chose App Engine
and did you evaluate any alternatives, work
us through the [INDISTINCT].
>> Guang: So just to give you a little background,
based on what we have done is we've created
the Socialwok, right, and you can check out
socialwok.com, it's basically a call service
for everybody social. And, because of that,
we want to do everything in [INDISTINCT],
right, and we looked at alternatives like
the EC2, Amazon's EC2 and S3, and we also
possibly looked at our own server [INDISTINCT].
But at the end of the day, we settled on App
Engine because we felt that it was highly
scalable, right, and enabled us at very low
cost to create a web application very quickly
and host it on, in this case, App Engine Java
on Google and we did not worry too much about
the scaling app, right? And because it's based
on Google infrastructure and we are selling
as a small start-up enterprise, too, we could
always leverage on Google's security, functionalities
and, you know, scalability, arguments, and
that allow us to go to market quite nicely.
>> Rangnekar: In short, I always, you know,
say this, is that we're software developers
not system administrators, and Google App
Engine actually allow us to, you know, be
just that software developers.
>> Kumar: Another thing we do and we use is
we use the Java language for App Engine. And
the great thing about that is that, you know,
while we don't really want to love App Engine,
we love App Engine because it's great. We
like developing with the flexibility of being
able to say, you know what, we move this far.
And that's really why we chose the App Engine
Java language support. We believe that Google
is right on in saying you should be able to
move stuff off of our infrastructure as part
of that new edition and some things like that.
So what we're--our view is that, you know,
either probably we're going to stick with
App Engine and then we'll always have one
or two customers who are going to say, let's
stay off with one or more [INDISTINCT].
>> Guang: Just a quick cap to Naveen, enterprise
portability, especially now space enterprise,
people like to have portability as an option.
And I think what App Engine Java offers is
very cheap. And, lastly, also for developers,
you have free callers. What's not to like
about free callers that allows you to test
your app adoption? So, I highly encourage
everyone, if you're doing any kind of application
and you want data portability, you want security,
and you want to be as close to enterprise
tech as possible, I would say App Engine Java
is the way to go.
>> Sauer: Maybe you can share your thoughts
on a distributed datastore versus traditional
relational model. How does that work for you?
And what advice do you maybe have for other
developers thinking about a transition?
>> Kumar: So, the thing is it really does
require you to change, you know, your mindset
when you're, you know, going in. You know,
people, you know, most people when they use
the traditional tools, they're using Joints.
You know, it's famous, you know, what's famous
about the App Engine datastores is the datastore
does not support Joints, so that's almost
one of the first things you have to start
changing how you program stuff. You start
thinking about how do I normalize these things,
break them down into multiple queries? Also,
you know, one of the things that we all, we
actually looked at is there's a certain niceness--niceties
about the way App Engine index is certain
entities, one of the things that when you
start developing, you realize that all queries
are based on index is that you have to define
in your application. Well, one of the beauties
of these indexes is that many of these indexes
can contain multiple values. So, a lot of
the times, you can basically perform queries
that are very optimal that allow to do a lot
of powerful things. You just have to kind
of work your way around it, realize it. And
one of the great things about App Engine is
there's a lot of great documentation, videos,
demonstrations, things that basically automatically
that already tell you, you know what, you
know, these things are out there, you should
check them out. So that's sort of how we kind
of got around these things.
>> Sauer: Okay. Would you describe a distributed
model as more complicated than a relational
model? Or how would you compare the two?
>> Kumar: So, it's just it's very different.
It's very different. It can be complex when
you start dealing with certain things like
[INDISTINCT] and [INDISTINCT]. When you start
getting into those areas, you'd think it's
very complex, but from the initial point of
view it's more about changing how you basically
write stuff. So, much of the stuff, much of
the code that you write normally from the
first, in the first place, is not that complex
per se. It's just a little bit of a different
way around a certain problem. And so once
you kind of get that, you can develop pretty
quickly. Then when you want to sort of start
working on the complicated things, item [INDISTINCT],
things like consistency, transactions are
a good example of things that work differently
on App Engine, the App Engine datastore than
they do in normal relational database, that's
when things start to get complex and you start
thinking about really, you know, developing,
you know, in a very strict way.
>> Sauer: Okay. Are there things about the
App Engine datastore that are actually easier
than on a relational database, things that
you could do now that maybe harder to get
to perform correctly in a relational world?
>> Kumar: It's hard to say that. One of the
things that I originally pointed out earlier
is the multi-valued nature of the indexing.
So, one of the cool things about the App Engine
datastore is its multi-valued property. So,
multi-valued properties in Java basically
show up as, you know, collections, lists,
so a lot of times you refer to them as list
properties, you know, if you're familiar with
the Python, where in Java it's more collection
properties, things like that, of that nature.
So, those things are really, really cool because
you can actually do queries on those properties
just like you do queries on single-valued
properties, and that actually can do a lot
of very scalable optimal things. And it's
not that hard to really, you know, code that
stuff up, it might be a little bit weird to
sort of look at those queries.
>> Rangnekar: And if you don't really want
to get into, you know, too much complexity,
you can always just use JDO, which is a familiar
concept in most Java, your app would still
work fine.
>> Sauer: Okay. Can you talk maybe about some
of your other experiences with the platform
to date?
>> Kumar: So, a couple of other experiences
we've seen is weíre pretty much at the
cutting edge of most stuff, so, you know,
as soon as things get released, we tend to
start using those features, things like the
task use which are really, really useful for
us especially an app like as complex as this
and so we need to do things that run in the
background that don't affect the user. A couple
of other things that we've run into, we had
to actually do it on our own search engine
on App Engine. And, you know, while it seems
kind of weird to say that Google is a search
company and they don't have full-time search
on their datastore, we know that's complex,
and what we've done is we simply got around
those problems using certain things that Google
themselves have already sort of provided.
>> Guang: I'd like to add, I mean, from a
developing point, when you develop, you run
into problems, right, so, to date our experience
of App Engine has been great. The IRC channels
are a good example. You guys have impromptu
chats, the forms are not bad, you have a lot
of knowledge base there, but I also want to
add that, you know, for example, for Socialwok's
case, right, we actually gave a talk at Google
tech not too long ago for the secondary JUG
and we were fortunate to be able to invite
Max Ross. He's an actual developer on the
Google App Engine Java datastore team, right.
So that level is sort of really an interaction
you can't really get anywhere else.
>> Sauer: Okay, great. Well, thank you for
your time and thanks for talking to us today.
>> Guang: Thank you.
>> Naveen: Thank you.
>> Rangnekar: Thank you.